20h50 émoi dans la communauté
scientifique internationale une équipe
de chercheurs américains a en effet
réussi une expérience de clonage de
plusieurs cellules d'embryons humains
une expérience qui pose bien des
questions en termes d'éthique ou de
morale nous y reviendrons dans un
instant avec notre invité le professeur
frydman le clonage consiste pour
schématiser bien sûr à effectuer une
sorte de photocopies de cellules et donc
à créer un être rigoureusement
similaires à son modèle précisons tout
de suite avec phil dumez pour fabriquer
deux individus rigoureusement identique
on appelle cela des clones il suffit ou
presque de coupé en deux un oeuf fécondé
d'environ huit jours seulement
chaque morceau dans bryant sera ensuite
replacé dans une enveloppe est
réintroduit dans l'utérus féminin
rappelons qu'à ce stade chacune des
cellules contient le même patrimoine
génétique
on obtient ainsi la naissance de copie
conforme des clauses les chercheurs de
l'institut national de la recherche
agronomique en france pratiquent déjà
cette technique pour obtenir des lapins
des agneaux et même des bovins
rigoureusement jumeaux l'idée étant
d'améliorer les espèces animales en
gagnant une vingtaine d'années de
sélection
l'expérience menée par les chercheurs
américains procèdent de la même démarche
mais cette fois avec des embryons
humains
jerry hall auteurs de cette manipulation
s'est borné prétend qu'il a cloné des
cellules anormales c'est-à-dire
incapable de se développer
aucune d'ailleurs survécu plus de 6
jouer l'une des premières applications
serait de faciliter la conception pour
des couples stériles
en revanche cette expérience permettra
aussi d'obtenir le bébé de son choix
avec cette technique
on pourrait par exemple un jour vous
dire choisissez nous en avons comme ça
une dizaine de génie au congélateur
plus préoccupant encore on pourrait
sélectionner les individus en fonction
de certains gènes de leur sexe cela est
déjà le cas avec les bovins suivant que
l'on souhaite faire des deux pour la
viande ou des vaches à lait avec nous
vous le voyez sur votre écran rené frieh